hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in the New
York Park uh where a lot of people get
together to play chess it's a game
between a hooded gentleman I do not know
his identity and feed the master of the
woman also known as Tani and uh it's
quite a game quite a game where the
king's Gambit is basically refuted it's
not refuted at its core because of
course you can play it but uh you know
you you will if you face the king's
Gambit quite a lot and if you struggle
with it maybe you can use this in your
own games and Bobby Fischer even
he wrote an article after he lost Boris
paski if you remember we've covered the
game if you haven't seen it do check it
out I will put also a link to that game
in the description below how Boris paski
defeated Bobby Fisher in their first
ever game uh using the king's Gambit and
then Bobby wrote this article saying
that the king's Gambit is is a terrible
opening that it just loses by force and
then he sort of refuted it so if you're
interested in Bobby Fischer's analysis
of the opening it will also be in the
description below uh probably second
thing you will see and also the third
thing you will see in the description is
the actual video of them playing this
game if you guys want to see them in
action I do suggest you watch it it's a
Blitz game so it doesn't take a whole
lot of your time but there is uh quite a
lot to enjoy and there are many hidden
lines here that you guys will appreciate
uh so let's dive straight into it uh the
hooded gentleman has the white pieces
and he opens with E4 we have E5 and as
advertised the king's Gambit is on the
board Ponta F4 we have e captures on F4
Knight to F3 and now in that article if
you click on it Bobby Fisher suggests
spawn to D6 as uh the best way to treat
the king's Gambit sort of a waiting move
and then well read his analysis if you
guys are into that but yeah there are
many many good moves here today at the
most uh common way of treating this is
the way it was treated in the old days
basically in the era of morphine
Anderson G5 is the serious attempt at
refuting the Gambit and it can be played
but Tony goes for Knight to E7 and it's
also one of the most annoying lines to
play against because uh black gets the
key BDF for Pawn usually white will just
develop the Knight play D4 and recapture
the pawn with Bishop captures on F4 but
now after Pawn to D4 we ignite the G6
just defending the pawn on F4 we have
knighted the C3 now and just Bush of the
E7 and if you want you could uh maybe
try something like Ponte H4 if you want
to try to kick away the Knight then
black will just play Pawn to H5 and if
you try something like Knight the E2 you
want to go after the pawn here then you
just allow black to really develop Pawn
to D5 attacks the E4 pawn and then after
E5 this bishop to H4 is now uh quite a
problem for you in some lines you can
even play G3 but this is not one of them
for example g3f5 captures on G3 and now
if H characters you're just gonna bring
the bishop back Bishop to E7 and you
haven't recaptured the pawn you've just
messed up your Pawn structure and black
will have an okay game this is not lost
for white uh by force but it will give
black a very very decent game so instead
after Bishop t7 the hooded gentleman
continues with Bishop to C4 if you by
any chance know who this is do mention
in the comments uh so so you know
everyone knows but I I was unable to
find out
uh and here we have castles just uh
castling the king the safety uh sorry
the castles by black uh and uh although
uh now Bishop to H4 check is is possible
and now it would be pretty bad I'm just
gonna show it to you because it's super
fun if Bishop page for check G3 you're
gonna uh capture on G3 now Bishop
captures on G3 but after King the E2 now
the G file is also open and with the H
file open the G file open the bishop and
this diagonal this is sort of a dream
position for white when playing the
king's gamut for example castles Bishop
G5 the the you cannot push the F1 you
have to play Queen the E8 now comes
Queen to G1 and after the bishop moves
let's say Bishop four Knight captures
Bishop captures night captures with
checking D2 now look at this The Rook
controls H file Queen controls the G
file Bishop controls this diagonal the
knights are beautifully placed the other
Rook is coming to F1 uh this is uh
completely winning for wise there is no
playing this position so instead after
Bishop to C4 like we said atani just
castles we have Castles by the hooded
gentlemen and now Pawn to D6 we have
knighted the D5 sort of breaking opening
principles here moving the same piece
twice out of the opening but you want to
win the bishop pair so it's Justified
Bishop to E6 and now Queen to E2
developing the queen and also now if the
bishop moves then
if the Knight moves the bishop on C4
will be defended so here Tani gives up
the light Square Bishop Bishop
characters and now he plays C6 further
chases away the bishop Bishop to B3 and
now Knight the D7 you have to continue
development and now Pawn to C4 this is a
a positional error by white uh yes you
want to control the center but not too
much Center here by playing Pawn to C3
you would actually have more control
over the center because after black
plays C5 you don't have to worry about
um uh your opponent D4 being removed
here I have to upon the C4 tan
immediately challenges it with C5 and
now D4 uh uh upon will fall you can play
D5 but that's just bad your your light
Square Bishop is just terrible here and
well you've given up the E5 Square for
the Black Knight that's not really good
so Bishop to D2 yeah white just
continues development C capture Sandy
for Knight captures and now Queen to B6
makes sense as the die diagonal has now
opened up Bishop to C3 defending the
Knight and now Bishop to F6 piling up on
the D4 Knight Rook 8 to D1 and now Rook
8 to E8 you could also consider a move
like Knights the C5 or Bishop to E5 but
uh tiny goes for Rook to E8 and now okay
Bishop T4 this could be uh annoying but
you can just move the Rook to E7 so it's
not a problem we have Queen to G4 and
now we have Knight Dita E5 going after
the queen here uh even though yeah it
seems like your knight here is hanging
so you have to move it but uh just for
fun I will show you root captures an E4
can be played and now if Queen captures
and D7 you will just play Bishop
captures on D4 and after Bishop captures
Rook captures now you are threatening
all sorts of nasty discoveries so the
king will have to move you're gonna play
Rook captures Rook captures and now play
something like Queen to F2 and you don't
really have time to go after the D6 Pawn
as F3 is coming and you are just lost
here is white
so after Queen G4 Knight D to E5 by Tony
going after the queen and this is a
Blitz game I'm only showing you these
extra lines for your inter entertainment
Queen back to E2 and now yeah you could
play a lot of moves here like the Knight
can come back the C6 you could start
advancing with Pawn to H5 uh but tanigos
Pawn to F3 and it makes sense you wanna
really free up this F4 Square for the
Knight to go after the queen G captures
an F3 notice that the Knight cannot
capture even though if you check out the
video in the description uh the who did
the gentleman actually picks up the
Knight and he wanted to grab the F3 Pawn
with the Knight but then he realizes
that he he can't even though it would be
a great move so G capture is an F3
Knights the F for now now you can see
how the the how black species are
starting to pile up in front of the
white king queen to D2 going after the
Knight and now look at this Knight eat
the D3 and it looks very scary now this
Knight cannot move because this Knight
hangs this Knight cannot move because
this Knight hangs but yeah you are not
in time to attack the Knight because
your uh Knight on D4 is hanging so you
have to first end to that so Queen to E3
and now Knight the H3 with check King G2
you could also play King H1 uh but
Black's movie is the same so Knight D
comes to F4 with Chuck King the H1 and
now Queen the C5 preparing to uh shift
to the queen over to the king side
notice how the knights are covering G1
and G2 squares so you can't really put
the Rook on a on the semi-open G file
and the black is free to just Mount the
attack
um as slowly as he wants so Knight the
C2 offering a queen trade matani just
declined with Queen to G5 Rook to D2 now
you have to threat uh you have to defend
against the mate threat with Queen to G2
uh so Rook to D2 and now Bishop captures
and C3 and this is a beautiful
a beautiful move uh because your Bishop
here is one of the few pieces that is
not involved in the attack the knights
are attacking the white king the queen
is very nicely placed the bishop however
not attacking the King on H1 uh and also
you're you're just in the way of a nice
Rook leave imagine rookie 6 Rook to G6
putting even more pressure on that
King's side so Bishop captures on C3
giving up your Bishop that's not really
doing all that much for White's very
very strong dark Square Bishop so B
captures on C3 and now I know you guys
know what's coming Rook to E6 a very
nice Rook lift and now comes Knight to
E1 uh here if you try C5 it looks like
it could be it could be something you
open up a discovery and The Rook it
doesn't really matter just Rook H6 or
something and if C captures on D6 uh you
can just recapture I mean uh the The
Rook still cannot move because of this
Checkmate and you only help the black
develop so instead after Rook D6 Knight
the E1 a very nice uh move as it also
covers the G2 square and now comes Rook
the G6 we have Pawn to C5 you have to
play something and white is pretty much
out of moves D captures on C5 and now
Bishop to D5 going after the B7 pawn and
now Tani just plays H5 You Wanna Give
Your King some breeding room here on H7
so you don't have to worry about any
back rank issues Bishop captures on B7
the the move doesn't really achieve all
that much you grab a pawn but what you
really do is allow Tani to activate his
last piece and that is the rook and f8
Rook the B8 now attacks the bishop on B7
Bishop to D5 and now Rook the B1 and
look at this now every piece of Tanis is
attacking the white king and if white
makes even a slight imprecision it is it
is game over black is completely winning
whatever white does but just to give you
uh an example of what's hidden in the
position let's say you play A3 what are
the are the threats here there are so
many threads here I'm just going to show
you the the ones that are the the most
fun look at this Knight the D3 what what
is this what kind of a movie is this the
the Knight can be captured by the Knight
by the rook and by the queen but
whatever you do you are just getting
Checkmate in the in most devious ways
possible look at this if Knight captures
on D3 then comes Rook captures an F1
with check you have to block Queen to G1
and then just Rook captures and G1 or
queen captures and G1 will deliver
Checkmate so obviously the Knight cannot
move what happens if Rook captures well
then you've lost the one of the
Defenders of the G2 square and now look
at this a beautiful queen sacrifice
Queen to G2 check Knight captures on G2
now look at this Rook captures on F1
with check only move Queen to G1 and now
this spectacular smothered mate Fork
combo uh I mean this is just uh
are absolutely spectacular I I don't
think we've ever had a like a smothering
mate Fork combo this is beautiful stuff
so that's what happens if the Rook
captures if the queen captures the
Knight then comes Queen to G1 check
another very nice sacrifice of Rook
captures and then just Rook captures and
G1 will be Checkmate and of course now
that you see that the Knight cannot be
captured you might think well let's just
trade Queens obviously you're not gonna
Checkmate me if I trade Queens uh yes he
is if Queen captures on G5 you're just
gonna recapture and whatever y does it's
still Checkmate uh again if something
like not a rook captures on D3 the queen
isn't really needed Knight to F2 with
check you even sacrifice the Knight The
Rook captures an F2 Rook captures anyone
with check and now only move is Rook to
F1 followed by Rook captures an F1
Checkmate as this recovers the the G2
Square
so after this work the B1 move those are
the threats in the position if white
doesn't uh find some miraculous move
that solves all of this which of course
uh did not happen as it's impossible uh
so white decided to uh to go out swing
he didn't want to you know just just uh
surrender here he played Bishop captures
on F7 King captures an F7 and now Rook
the d8 sorry Rook to d8 uh and here Tani
uh thought about the position for a few
seconds and then he just captured the
free rook as the hooded gentleman
blundered an entire Rook uh and he was
in this position on move 33 that the
hooded gentleman resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
it's made in in whatever you want uh you
know whenever you want it but when you
will be retelling the story of this game
and maybe even showing it to your
friends in the bar in the library you
can also show Queen the G2 check as the
smother in mate is still possible Knight
captures on G2 Rook characters on F1
Queen to G1 and now again the Beautiful
Finish Knight to F2 a beautiful smother
checkmate
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
hope you guys enjoyed it if you struggle
against the the king's Gambit and there
are many ways uh of uh dealing with the
king's Gambit you could accept it you
could go for for the folk beer counter
Gambit you could uh you know just play
the main line with um
uh with advancing the the H Pawn like
we've discussed but also this e captures
an F4 Knight F3 and knights the E7 can
be really really Troublesome for white
as uh once this D4 movies played white
will uh White will struggle I mean is it
just uh people who play the Kings Gambit
on a club level player they are they are
very much used to playing D4 E4 Knight
F3 and then just recapturing the pawn on
F4 we do playing 97 Knights the G6 yes
you've spent two moves developing your
knight but then your your opponent will
be like but yeah well what what do I do
now it's it's very unclear uh so yeah
maybe if you guys like it you can try it
in your own games uh and hopefully uh
win some nice nice ones as uh well as
you've seen that it's possible Tani yeah
we really played a beautiful game here
and who the gentleman really played a
very strong game as well it I mean it
wasn't until maybe like move 25 that he
did his first not not a blunder but
first the inaccuracy so uh I mean even
uh when the position was completely
crazy the engine said it was like this
0.00 so it's uh it's a fun opening but
you it doesn't seem that you risk all
that much
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for suggesting such
a lovely game like I said in the
description you can check out Fisher's
game versus Spa scheme uh in in the
king's Gambia you can check out Bobby
Fisher's article about the uh you know
the king's Gambit after he lost that
game to sparsky and also you can check
out the actual footage of this game
those will be the first three links in
the description below so if you have
some extra time uh do check it out not a
bad way to to spend the day uh so yeah
once again really hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Jack obey the
goncalo marovo Martin Georg paparik
sofos
uh subramanian for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day